welcome to Tom Pappas come to Papa hey
everybody welcome to another edition of
come to Papa your favorite podcast among
all the other podcasts because ours is
filled with hardcore positivity how's it
going Paul good where are we all tell
our viewers where we are why like Ximena
whirlwind we are in the greatest city in
the world New York City at the
world-famous smut probably the most
famous comedy club in the world the
Comedy Cellar that's right
technically upstairs at the Aubrey's a
where you wait to go on downstairs for
your your comedy the cellar Comedy
Cellar is actually in a cellar right and
we are upstairs in the beautiful cafe
what an amazing New York day it is crisp
it is clean thunderstorms rolled through
last night and took a hot muggy Father's
Day weekend and sent it packing yeah
that's what it does to you it it beats
you down and then when you get like an
hour of pleasant weather yeah you just
go crazy and enjoy it people are almost
like ripping their clothes off running
down the street right I literally saw a
couple people that look like they might
take their clothes off and then I asked
them if they would and they declined
because they move along but yesterday
was a nightmare that that was a brutal
like New York hustle day that was just
sweaty every ass wedding everyone's
running everyone's everyone's trying not
to move and you still are sweating your
ass yeah yeah but I was still rocking a
jacket like a gentleman yeah that was
crazy cuz I started walking and then I
stopped just because I'm like I know I'm
going to sweat for a few minutes right
now so I need any like just go inside
went to the NHL store dislike why did
you go there just cool off and see yeah
see I like going to the NBA store I'll
go to the NHL store I'll go to the
adidas store check out the toy makers I
like me to buy anything no no nothing
nothing
you just loiter them there until you
know what's coming out and then I can
see where I can get it cheaper in a
couple months so you were trying to bond
with that we you and I went up to the
Sirius XM studio yeah thanks great been
aiming depending tonneau yes and we have
to make sure Gail's on the list for
tonight we have the live show that's
right reason we're here folks is that
we're doing the live show in couple
hours and so we were running around
there trying to UM to our Sirius XM
thing and I was looking at your
impressive Yankee hat and you were all a
fluster because your shoes matched a rap
star named big boy yes from Outkast Tom
from Outkast that should have been here
they were famous in like the late 90s he
was at heart of Outkast he was the other
guy it was Big Boi and Andre 3000 those
are the two guys Wow
I totally didn't know that so the heya
and so yeah ends in um something like a
Polaroid picture yeah yeah that's him
was it flip it like a Polaroid today
shake it like a shake what happened to
those guys well before he was still at
Sirius XM we go solo yeah they've been
that's the whole thing I think Andre
3000 started he was supposed to play
Jimi Hendrix hidden like that the bio
movie I don't know if that ever came out
they split up because they were really
famous and they both did their own
separate things and then I write they're
like they're using Atlanta they're like
they have a whole industry they have
their own clothing stores and obviously
they're like Russell Simmons down there
well you were very happy that your
fashion was matching his fashion yeah
and you there's a glass thing at Sirius
XM where they call the fishbowl right
it's a glass dinning room and they do a
lot of live music in there and
interviews and things like that when
they want to make a spectacle out of it
and Paul was just pressing
face against glass waving a big boy who
is a big boy yeah a big african-american
rap guy he has chain and his posse those
are two things that you need
yes very intimidating give any correct
look I have the same shoes as you look
at me look at me look at my shoes and
they had their security to get you off
the glass
yeah well Liz here is a big sneaker head
she's got more adidas than she'll even
admit to do you know that no I did not
know that yeah that's what she said
she's addicted to it that's what we will
always talk about small again if I have
my adidas on now but you normally Rock
Nike don't I know but we're and then we
just got the the Barbados Congress which
Nike owns now yeah it's all back
together I can't keep up with you and
your rap friends you guys have a whole
nother life going on I have no posse I
come into Sirius XM by my cell right in
a sport coat in the summer and I have no
posse that don't you have to pay all
these people who walk around with you I
don't know no they don't just come with
you right not I can only bring one
person and yeah I am 14 they've gotta be
on the payroll you got to make money if
you're going to have a posse but then I
see people that don't have a much money
walking around with a posse just hoping
that he makes it one day I always like
looking at the couch and like all right
where does it stop that the rest of
these people are staying in New Jersey
tonight right boy gets to stay and the
ridge overlooking the park everybody get
off his couple people are at HOD 51 and
then everyone else is at the Sheraton in
the Meadowlands yeah I have to say this
is the first time I'm coming in where
I've been here for several days because
we did the great shows in Connecticut we
had a blast field in Old Saybrook over
the weekend they were amazing shows
beautiful theaters make great people and
and then we had Father's Day and we and
it's been now I guess four days five
days since we've been here already yeah
and it's the first time I'm doing some
come to Papa where I'm not seriously jet
lag yeah
yeah I got I had a crazy day yesterday
where we did we did radio I did another
travel uh like podcast write edit guys
it was you have you ever heard of venmo
know like the pav mo the discount liquor
store venmo Oh mmmm oh it's the thing
that kids venmo the discount venereal
disease place I guarantee your daughters
are paying all these uh food delivery
people with venmo
that's how they do it that's the no they
use instacart it's new like you know
they use instacart and they use a papist
mate right but if they want to pay each
other like if they go to movies and say
hey can you buy my ticket to spend money
that's what like younger people do now
because nobody carries waiting you're my
daughter's at the movie theater she
wants a ticket somebody said hey they're
gonna sell tonight I'll get the tickets
right you guys can just venmo me or that
they'll do it like for a dinner and then
what happens when they venmo
like an instant thing and I don't know I
think it's just because they have
everyone to email and it builds up like
a database I think that's how they make
money but they don't take the fees out
that PayPal does so you can send oh oh I
look like you need so me money I need to
send you money it's yeah just venmo me
that's like the new oh it's new like hip
thing that broke people do if you've got
20 bucks and you owe someone ten you
just know I'm so glad I'm not poor
well it's like a huge deal I guess and
so this guy just happened to have like
an Eagles Jersey one night in a bar
right and this guy's like hey I'll give
you it was like a rare player like
somebody from the Giants that we would
only appreciate like the kicker or
something like that right and the guys
like I'll give you $1,000 for the Jersey
and he's like okay he's like how are you
paying us out of the dollars and the
guy's like rich from this he invented
Ben mo or something so he has this whole
beautiful studio I'm like 23rd Street
it's all musicians and stuff and then
three idiots doing a podcast in one of
the what specifically you were yeah yeah
how did you get involved with these
people they're they're the one guys
names Turner sparks he ran the
the english-speaking comedy club in
China for 12 years oh my god oh that's a
guy you did that gig no you didn't do
try I didn't do it Ari did it and I
think butch Bradley do you other guys
right over and did it but he ran the
club when he lived there for 12 years
and he just moved back like in the last
year and his wife is still in China she
they're trying how do you hook up with
his Chinese he was it used basketball
fans right - so we just he wanted to
have me on just talk about traveling
because I went to Asia last year now
talking about basketball and all that
kind of area that was fun and I did
already Lang's podcast after that over
in New Jersey man and then I had learned
my haka and then I had to bring my
stupid rental car back JFK Airport No
yeah you drove all the way out to JFK
Holly back there get there no one's at
the desk
no one's anywhere there's five cop cars
the Hertz employees gotten a fistfight
with each other it's 2:00 in the morning
what you did this at 2:00 in the morning
well that's what I ended up finally
getting home this is like one this is
like after after that and then uh yeah
there's there's like a little circle
where the Train is there's five cop cars
two guys arguing with each other the one
guy did take his hurt shirt off he was
done with it but I was just like hey I'm
just trying to just trying to drop off
my car how did you get back
I just took it over back because it was
just too late to figure it out Oh Mike I
never really figured out what a
nightmare
they've never figured out the JFK thing
so by three o'clock you're rolling back
into Manhattan so I got back like 233
and then yeah just crashed like I knew I
was just going to be so busy today and
tomorrow that and you fly back tomorrow
tomorrow like a 1 I don't feel crazy
what about you you just stay in weeks
yeah I'm like I'm yeah I don't know how
we're going to do the pockets next week
but I'm going to be here for a quite a
while New York residency I know it kind
of feels that way and yeah it feels it
feels all right so what'd you end up
doing
I went to father's day first of all oh
yeah yeah sorry I went to you have to be
sorry
sorry you saw your father yeah I Drive
back after I show an old saybrook
through the through the fog to see my
father and I realized I said this on
Saturday Father's Day is you know it's
just another Mother's Day it's just
another day that uh mom can get
everybody together right and you
couldn't follow like you yeah it's good
to see you you know what I don't know
how excited everybody is yeah well I
mean it's just a reason all sit in the
same room I get it it doesn't have to be
a big festival but the same time it's uh
the moms are more happy about it right
dad so you two rather just had a day by
yourself that would have been a gift it
was okay I had my uh my youngest one was
out with me on the East Coast so I got
to hang with her and that was cute that
was nice yeah you sacrificed you could
have stayed at this five-star hotel with
a pool in Old Saybrook whoo-hoo we were
at that place was such a dump we did
this great Little Theater in Old
Saybrook the show was great the people
were great the little town is amazing we
spent the day there it was everything
positive we stayed and out play put him
out L I don't think I've been in one
that bad uh in a long long time may 20
years it smelled like a nursing home I
won't mention the name of it because
yeah I don't know who's connected to it
but I just know that there was no
quality in that hotel it was brutal
it was the kind of place where you you
know we always go through this you
you're on the road you just banging it
out you're doing your shows you don't
want to be a prima donna you're not
trying to be a diva you just want to
roll in whatever it is it doesn't have
to be fancy and then you walk into some
places and it's like it's impossible for
you for it you not to complain yeah
we're gonna we're going to hit you with
everything we're going to hit you with
beds that look like a fat man has been
sleeping in it for 20 years
we're going to have a a
air freshener that smells like a nursing
home toilet yeah we are going to give
you a view of route 95 blaring out your
window literally while your ear
air-conditioning did you notice it was
it was back by the time he left
yeah that's Oh was is just a hole no all
the wall where the air conditioner was
just a pool of water and I was like all
right I guess I'm just going to drive
two and a half hours to my father's
house and be there for father's day like
it like I was a hero like I just
couldn't be away from the family but it
was almost impossible
you stay there during the night due to
get crazy during the night no don't
forget too bad people weren't screaming
that wedding party there was a giant
wedding in a school bus well the thing
is I do like we've stayed in some really
nice places but I do like the fact that
if you're close enough to get to where
you would call home or family that you
can just get the hell out of there and
yo what's your cutoff my cutoff when I
was a young comedian if I'm within 12
hours drive I'll do it yeah now I'm
about to write and this was two and a
half so I felt like I was pushing it a
little bit but you also were like you
your parents are there your daughter's
there so then you kind of well you love
is overly that you were there at a
reasonable time I'm rolled in around
12:30 wasn't it bad
nothing like stopping at a few food and
fuel on Route 95 by yourself at midnight
I think maybe I've made the wrong
decision yeah maybe
this is where it all ends when they're
just looking at you as you're pulling
your money out of your wallet and you
know when I'm young when I was young I
didn't think about that so much just
going to blaze him he had nothing they
could steal mm-hmm and your life wasn't
that important no one was relying on you
yeah at this point you're standing there
in this one guy just picking his teeth
and looking at you and you're like this
might not be the wisest decision yeah my
only rule is no rest stops I went to
like a rest stop when I used to drive
back and forth to Sacramento for
reading right now girl you know I'd be
driving at 1:00 or 2:00 in the morning
stopped at a rest stop tepee and there
was like a gang meeting in there
and I just kind of like waved and get
around just like turned around went off
easy there Riley you know they're really
not policed very well yeah did I tell
you the one when I got when my car broke
down in high school at a rest stop and I
was driving down to the Jersey Shore in
my little Toyota Corolla and my car
conked out and it was always coming
honking out and this time it conked out
and I pulled into this rest area and it
wouldn't start again
so it's dead so you got it to the rabbit
ear the rest area it was just kind of
sputtering I got it into this tiny
little rest area it wasn't much it was
like one little strip and a single
payphone mm-hmm and so I'm trying to get
triple-a I'm trying to get these people
to come and rescue me and all this on
the phone rings oh the payphone Oh like
I guess I'll answer it you know that
weird feeling when you there and the pay
phone goes hi guy pick it up and I
answer the phone and they say it's a guy
and he says uh hey um what's going on
and like many of them I'm you know I'm
17 I'm I'm nothing what uh what's
happening down there I'm like gee mister
I think you got at this place confused
this is a rest area lady Joe's bar yeah
he's like yeah yeah I know what's what's
going on I said uh no again this is a
rest area and I just hang up and they're
waiting he didn't say are you from the
future
Yeah right you know it's Tom those are
the rings again ringing ringing I pick
it up hello
so uh what are you into what am i into
and then finally like sixth time my
little 17 year old brain goes oh hang up
the phone really quickly and then the
tow truck pulls up and the guy gets out
like this big Italian guy and he's
got a tire iron in his hand like and
he's looking paranoid looking around and
he goes hurry up
where's your guy we got a tow and get
out of here oh my oh its manic is it all
gay rest area well every time every time
I come here they hit on me look at it
like he's gonna be attacked like he's
like he's that desirable yeah but you
know this was 1987 or whatever and I'm
like oh that's what the guy in the pay
phone was in to jump my little shorts I
jump into this guy's track he was with
me and my car away and we we got away
without any game to lose I just had like
a guys running up behind him trying to
pull his pants down or something
yeah well that's creative yeah I think I
know it's so funny to think about a fact
that he was that he was that bad upset
by it yeah the rest areas could be dicey
when you if you're a straight young man
especially that's the thing is like it's
late at night I'm just peeing on the
side of the road right are you no no we
just can pull on to the shoulder I'm
gonna stop it on the shoulder in the
middle of nowhere of course on a major
interstate like I'm route 95 no like if
I'm in if I'm driving from like San
Francisco to LA right that just miles of
farmland and just those exits that don't
even have on the 5 yeah I don't know I
always picture that's where the truck
runs into you well I pull off to like
the exit that doesn't even have anything
yeah and then then like the ramp that's
going back on and I'll go on the side
there ok
yeah no you're going to get in front of
a rest area right I hear you know if I
see someone coming obviously I'm
stopping anyway but this is like it's
not about you peeing and getting caught
it's about you not getting hit it's
about yeah someone running you over yeah
I have the light side of stuff it's not
like I'm trying to like be secret pee
guy or sometimes when Large Marge from
pee-wee's Playhouse
comes running into you and smacks you is
that the only time a car ever broke down
now broke down all the time yeah does it
in the city I was I was able to fix it
now is in New Jersey I was able to fix
it I had some tools
it would break down I would you know
know what I knew everything about it had
it since I was 16
yeah I had some tools and you didn't
need that many skills just only you know
certain number of parts on it you knew
it was easy the battery or starter
something with a carburetor you could
fix a starter yeah get in there and
knock it around get to the place replace
it I did my own brakes one time are you
serious yeah it was just like that was
your it was like your friend and you
just knew everything about it anything
that went wrong yeah I mean that you
didn't have money and they were simple
engines who just went in and fixed it
that sounds like the VW bus and yeah it
was similar a little like 86 Corolla
yeah
76 and yeah you just went in and like
fixed it up and went and one time I
drove with my friends and the lights
went out and there was no we had no
lights at all the alternator was messed
up so you could get it started but it
didn't even have enough power to keep
the lights on yeah and we're trying to
get down to the beach and we're cruising
along on this two-lane highway and
people are allowed to pass on those
highways I'm out you see the coast was
clear and you go for it and we see wait
I got like this is a tiny car and I've
got like six football players in it yeah
and we're driving along and my friends
holding a flashlight out on the white
line so I could see where could it go
you got the flashlight there with that
work and we see way in the distance a
big truck mm-hmm and that's fine
but then we see a guy like peek out from
the truck a little car from behind kind
of comes into our lane and goes back
then he comes back out and he's seeing
way down in our direction that the coast
is clear because he can't see us yeah so
he think he comes out a third time sees
the coast is clear and guns it right for
us oh man so worried
screaming this guy's coming right for us
at the last second he is enough light on
us and he cuts over it doesn't squash us
she's a weird freak that we're totally
freaked out we get out of that two-lane
highway through the Pine Barrens of New
Jersey and we get to like where
civilization is and we're like five
miles from where we're going down to the
Long Beach Island and a cop pulls us
over because she's five six guys stuffed
in a car like a clown car with no lights
and one guy hanging out with a
flashlight and he pulls us over and as
soon as he pulls us over
you have to stop when you stop the car
dies so the car dies and the guys like
what are you doing
we're like we've run out of power and
it's the alternator it happened he's
like well you're gonna have to call
someone cuz you can't drive this vehicle
right I'm like I was kind of like you
know wired because I'm traffic I just
returned to I said no seriously you
gotta let's go he's like you can't see
you've got the license my eyes are like
a cat I can make it that's when he gave
you the sobriety test yeah then he made
us they made our my parents come pick us
up yes you just wanted to make it though
that was the goal we were so close yeah
so close but that was it you just packed
that thing together and I did that
probably for five years and eventually
it just seized up and really died that's
crazy
yeah I couldn't fix anything I just knew
what was going wrong and kind of eased
into it like we had a 71 comet that was
my grandmother's car this is like in the
90s
and so it used to just stall out it was
automatic so I would drive through town
now go through like a light and outfield
saw and I would just ease it into
neutral and then I would just like pull
in front of like a newspaper stand or
something and even one day my buddy was
like hey why you always go to that
newspaper stand
I was like no the car stalls out and I
just pull he's like I couldn't even tell
man I was really smooth like use
impressed
I just glide right out failure but I
never the only time I ever broke down it
was like a freezing cold night like yeah
on the highway and I was near kind of
near home in college like in-between it
was like a 20-minute drive right and so
there's an old folks home that's like
back away from the highway but you can
see it but it's like I mean there's over
a foot of snow it's freezing yeah and
it's the one time like I got out and my
eye lids were actually like he could
feel them like getting hard icing out
yeah yeah so I jump I jumped the fence
to try to get to this old folks home and
I'm just freezing night but I make it
and I'm pounding on the door and those
guys like gets on the intercom he's like
yeah I'm not allowed to let anybody in I
was like I'm freezing man I broke down
the highways like yeah we got security I
can't let you in he that is like what
you would say if you were coming to kill
everybody right right you would say I
just broke down you gotta let me yeah
that's really that's when you try to
like ham I look like a nice guy right do
I look like I'm gonna murder somebody
like that's one wheel your friends and
have the crazy beards or something is
like that's when you don't get through
security or you you know yeah this is
look at his face let me in do you let
him know he called my buddy who was at
his dorm and he came and picked me up
but but I had to stay outside the whole
time so freezing there is a time and I
remember distinctly there was a moment
when I realized like for years you know
I was like oh I'm I'm like cute enough
to get out of trouble like you know I'm
just kind of friendly faced and young
and I remember it was like around 35 or
so I was on my like made a joke with a
flight attendant hmm and she wasn't as
amused as everybody had been in my
entire life I like threw my little
charming smile and I tried to like you
know give her that little cutesy look
and it didn't go over and I remember
thinking I wonder if I don't have that
anymore
and I didn't I really I noticed like now
now I'm like a man who like still
friendly but I didn't have that same
like youthful yeah cute I'm gonna get a
free pass anywhere I go
nothing retina but now I feel like
what's kind of I'm working a different
angle now it's like I'm the I'm like the
older nice guy in glasses I was just
going to say I think the glass is
brought it back for ya it really does it
it doesn't help you with young
attractive women they don't look at you
as a relevant option you know in the
game anymore but no but she'll get you
some coffee if you want yeah yeah I
think the glass look glasses look is
kind of like brought in this whole
nother angle it yeah yeah that was my
problem with what I was in I was going
to Toronto I was doing a show that saw
Rob Zombie was like two people ahead of
me we're in Toronto it was like two
summers ago and he's dressed like Rob
Zombie there's no day off from Rob
Zombie right Rob Zombie he's got the
skull on his cowboy hat or whatever yeah
Rockstar got a zombie talked to guards
showing and the beard and the sunglasses
and yeah so he he didn't even I can
count over here like they're like where
are you going and he's like I don't know
I got a show right I'm picking me up and
I can't tell this guy knows he's Rob's
because if you don't know he's Rob
Zombie then it's like alright is easing
the Hells Angels they're something
somebody's yeah you know and there's a
mom and I just let him straight through
and then so I go through got paperwork
clean shaven my collared shirt on if you
feel like yeah we need to take you in
the back I was like what this is like
the one time in life I get a pass that's
when you see a Rob Zombie walk through
ya know you can't tell and there's like
my one nephew looks like he looks Middle
Eastern his family's Italian and
and like English but he's really dark a
and had a beard appeared and he was like
college college-age kind of freaky kid
like letting his hair go crazy his beard
go crazy and he he gets stopped in
places and stuff you know in the second
look because he looks Middle Eastern
yeah well so you can't really tell
there's no way to really get a free
dance but whenever I would I would
definitely work my white angle whenever
I had to go get a loan or meet with a
lawyer we're trying to get my kids
accepted in a school I'm like I this is
I got I got a white it up and I was
throw on a button-down shirt and hide it
and then and walk in and welcome in the
eye and shake the hand and do all the
white guy stuff and you know that that's
a powerful that is a powerful technique
right there yeah it's just is the
dressing up thing that's what happens
there hurts
if I'm president circle and I'd go in
there with my shorts and my baseball hat
on yeah I'm not getting the Mercedes
okay they're going to give me the cube
yeah it is but then there's like then
there's the other the other end of it
when people are so big and famous that
they dress it down right that they just
go with like the black t-shirt and more
boots and just kind of like I'm just
gonna I'm gonna look like you know yeah
I got nothing you got new clothes every
day but you got to look like they are
worn and like that Fred Segal is just
all worn in t-shirts and yeah means John
Varvatos oh yeah it's all rich guy
clothes to look like poor people what
they wore clothes enough to wear them
out that's what that look is yeah if you
had so little money that you had to wear
these jeans for 25 years and we'll make
it more expensive than they ever were if
you're if you're just coming into this
podcast a little late if your friend has
it rolling we are at the Comedy Cellar
in New York City that's why you hear the
ambient noise of a festive New York cafe
on a beautiful summer night here in
beautiful Greenwich Village getting
ready to do our live show though I've
come to pop a show which we will
probably broadcast next week and it's
gonna be a good one with the hill on it
Jim Norton to to gold stacked yeah
everybody Harmon Lynch Rick chrome Ryan
Hamilton is going to close it out right
it's gonna be it's going to be a good
one so even if I even if my writing is
weak on this one I will be saved by the
the talent labra of a list comedians and
then after that pretty much I'm going to
do a bunch of spots but it's just pretty
much fun time yeah I don't have to be on
camera or really travel for a while are
you going to go beard are you gonna grow
it out I look so gross with it every
time I think I'm going to do it and it's
it's got grey in it and orange and like
this multicolored grubby guy look maybe
make it actually the more I say it it
was the more appealing it kind of sound
you could do the shaved head for the
next three weeks has the sunglasses and
a beard I was looking at I was writing
in the hotel lobby I love writing in a
hotel lobby
yeah bar restaurant I know a girl who
works at the bar in the hotel in it
where I'm at and the Soho grand downtown
and I go there all the time so people
they know me it's very comfortable I
love just sitting in there and writing
and you can write on these couches for a
while and then I after a while I move
into the bar where I know that gorilla
works the bar there and I sit with her
for a bit and do some more work with a
with a backrest it's just great you get
some work done and then you mail
something out it's like I live in a
hotel
I love that feeling and but as I was
sitting there writing there was a guy or
two guys businessmen bald like shaved
down bald huh and probably in their 40s
and bald and I gotta say it is
it's a man not an intimidating look it
makes anybody like you put hair on the
guy there's something soft and kind of
friendly yeah shave it all off there's a
little bit especially as a white guy
there's a little bit of a menacing yeah
sod to it it definitely depends because
you don't know whether it's a choice or
whether it's like a guy's doing it for
fashion yeah reasons or like bill bird
did it and everyone thought that he
looked meaner when he first did it yeah
because he had that kind of red curly
hair that was a little disarming that's
true yeah I think everyone's kind of
used to it now with him but he does look
a little meaner that he than he used to
yeah yeah it's interesting
rogon he's with me right right yeah he's
bald but those you know those guys if
you didn't know them as the comedian's
they are and whatever you would think
guys kind of I don't want to mess with
that guy right right I think you know I
mean I think those guys were a little
mean-looking anyway you know if there's
a guy that's been kind of nice and then
shades a head and then immediately you
were like oh he's a tough guy now like I
don't know yeah there's a I don't know
when I'm older and I'm have nothing left
I might just grow out the bottom like
and go Ben Franklin style oh yeah
well your dad does that a little bit I
get a little wacky like oh yeah my
father has the like the monk
yeah like the Friar Tuck around around
the edges yeah and it gets a little long
sometimes sometimes it's long sometime
but he's never shaved the whole thing I
know it's never shave the whole thing
down he's just look there's Robert
Kelley just walked in yeah he shaved his
head he shaved his head in he looks like
like Marlon Brando but could you ever
imagine him with hair at this point it
looked weird right it would look really
weird and Jim Norton like he looks like
like Brando they look like Brando in
Apocalypse Now he looks like Marlon
Brando in Apocalypse Now he's he's got
that gigantic belly and he doesn't try
to wear the smaller shared either he's
just really letting it dangle
hi Robert good to see you buddy how's it
going I was going Paul
that's what do you I see you I see you
[ __ ] on me talking to no low
self-esteem we're actually talking about
how smart you guys look you look very
smart over here because of our glasses
yeah well your glasses your faces your
hair we could literally we nails your
knees your kids we were literally just
talking about I saw a guy in the hotel
lobby and he had shaved his head and he
looked like it was just a businessman
I'm like even it doesn't matter how nice
a face you are if you shave your head
down you look a little more badass and
then you didn't you walk in I'm like and
there's Bobby yeah you have to shave the
whole thing though you can't do like the
side yeah the side you look you need to
be badass or homeless I mean shave what
do you mean like like Chile has shaved
the top but he has a side my father has
like the Friar Tuck you know around that
doesn't look badass I respect it I was
hanging with your uh you cub me and your
friend were hanging out a lot
Ari Shaffir no Jerry Seinfeld nope um
Jeff Garlin nope Steven Soderbergh yeah
what a great guy where are you hanging
with him I was doing his one of his
movies oh you are is that where you were
on set yeah yeah we're pals now he's the
greatest yeah we text she actually came
over Sunday from barbecue what I mean
now I know you're lying
get away
ha ha the barbecues barbecue the come
over line ha ha ha
I should have said dinner dinner would
have been more you know remember a
cocktail aha
Fidel going up to New York go to a
barbecue that was the greatest thing and
were you working on he has a movie out
that is crazy interesting
I can't assign some thing so I can't
talk about it but it's an independent
film that he shot
and the iPhone one yeah well then I
guess I can don't say it I didn't sign
in it you yeah you said it
oh and it's um it's a yeah yeah since it
well here's the thing sorry listeners
you'll find out when when I I got the
thing and I was like oh my god this is
Steven Soderbergh I was like wow this is
it was a small small part I had a small
part which is and then you show up in
its a regular movie and there's wardrobe
and there's a van and they drive it and
there's a PA and there's other stuff and
we're in the woods and blah blah blah
and this Steven I'm like oh my god he's
the nicest coolest really cool dude as
soon as you me music hey what's up hey
don't it's just really did I come up
yeah of course did you bring it up or
did he bring it up well I brought it up
but he immediately brought it up like he
was thinking about it too I was like I
want to totally blow up a friendship
with Tom make him Jeff he goes oh yeah
tell him with Texan fella you know we've
been texting today's and I was like go
ahead
haha so funny you both know how to bust
my balls but then he comes out of
nowhere and he they go okay put that
right over here
and there's a ladder and then there is
just an iPhone I'm like what the [ __ ] so
yeah he's but it did either
he's a genius first of all which is so
annoying because he's working on like 20
projects at the same time and he's
always making something always creating
something and every time I leave him
like we'll meet for a drink and he'll
tell me all the stuff that he's doing
and I walk out like what is wrong with
me
like what why am I so lazy you feel that
way with him I feel the same of it Louie
I leave like like I like you see what
he's doing and then you go home and I'm
like sitting outside on a chair in my
back yard oh my god this is nice and
then like oh god I should be doing
something do something with my iPhone or
my zoom or just drawing us something I
know and is it I mean part of me always
thinks well he but he's Betty Soderbergh
he's got he can go get things made and
get ends like but
and that's not it right no it said he
always does something and he's always
creating and me and you take naps to be
fair we do have children and wives who
want us to take care of those children
yeah I know but they would really want
us to take care of them like Louis Oh
Steven Soderbergh more than me are you
let's make something then why are we so
let's do something we I don't know see
that's where that's where it's Tom papa
and and Soderbergh begins I'm barely
getting through this podcast but if I
have to go through this live show we've
only been in here 39 minutes on mic week
we might only go 45 today podcasts are
real they're like fidget spinners
they're really just dying out but what
if I set up inviting both to be in the
movie and you come out and it's an
iPhone you guys are both sharing it over
back to the city right well can we talk
I mean is that that part I mean you
can't but you could talk about the can
you talk about the iPhone part of it no
about any of it I shot Rob Zombie who we
were just talking about my buddy
Rob Zombie shot the beginning of my
stand-up special on iPhones we had three
iPhones he had little lenses on him
William Stephenson was in it and we just
walked around New York and we put a
setting on it to make it look like the
70s and I was dressed like the 70s and
we just walked around and he shot it it
looked like a film because iPhone people
don't notice iPhone 7 shoots in 4k you
can download it in 4k which is fine for
television mm-hmm I mean Netflix Amazon
absolutely you can shoot on your iPhone
in 4k they have apps that shoot they
have so much capability instead of apps
that you can do what a can't read camera
does and editing you can edit right on
your computer
if so the wrong the eight millimeter app
do is the one yeah millimeter shoots it
does like every type of film like
there's a really no excuse for us to not
be creating something actually literally
go to for $200 go to the Apple store and
buy a
steadicam rig for your iphone alright
this is the end of my podcast career
because i'm going to be making movies
we're gonna be Woody Allen one a year
for the next 40 years yeah if I could
only get somebody that I did a day on
Louise movie and he's shooting the same
week I did the dan louise movies
he's shooting on black-and-white film so
it's literally the exact opposite worlds
yeah somebody has to literally drive to
Boston is the only place they develop
black and Pixar I have to so it's like
he went back in time and yeah yes well
it he hasn't made a lot of films sort of
words made so many of them the process
yeah no I know but I'm like soda burgers
shot film forever and then he moved to
the red cameras and now you go do it on
that good I'm telling you me it was it
was the best thing I've ever worked on I
mean you walk up it's such a relaxed
thing and you do your thing and it's
like okay cool you get you got it yep
that was the most intimidating thing
ball back when I was in a movie with
Steven Soderbergh on which one Tom I
don't know the first second or third one
I think it was the first the second
[ __ ]
I'm glad you weren't a Mike for that Tom
played himself
everybody loves the Nick still anytime
he go somewhere people the all the
people at Conan like of the Navy all of
them they all ask him like how how he
made those shops and see the but the
same thing is you the first time I ever
did a scene with him I thought we were
just practicing and he's like okay
that's good I'm like what and they're
like okay next scene he moved so quickly
he knows so clearly what he wants and he
knows that he got it you just move on to
the next scene you're like but I didn't
even try it
yeah the its reared his has it built
like it's almost like his self-esteem or
his knowledge of what he wants is so
precise that you almost like some
directors like I let me try this there
sometimes like they're making it up as
they go you feel like some directors are
making it
up and they're figuring it out with you
where he's just asking you to say these
lines do your acting and I got
everything else and you don't even know
like when you when it comes out like
you're like oh that's what he was
filming I like I wasn't even in the
scene it was like my hands going through
and capturing Michael Douglas that was
one of my co-stars yeah I had a Mike his
name's Mike just Mike good to see he's
good I he was in gypsy in Pittsburgh
learning it how's your podcast going my
podcast is actually going great
I saw a sticker for it in a weird place
it was a place where I wouldn't think
and I saw your mug up there I gave it a
bunch of stickers and so people to put
them in weird places yeah that's what I
got yeah I work yeah I really was like
how many cows it that wife Bobby holding
him microphone and his teeth up here
yeah I don't I just do it yeah yeah
what's the name of your podcast again
you know what did um it's called you
know what dude yes Oh anywhere comedy um
all right listen I'm out of here thanks
for stopping by this was a nice little
treat
have fun with your show tonight double
podcast right multi radio show this a
podcast yeah and then that one gets
rolled into a pot has it's gonna be a
good one
Jimmy Norton's making a return tonight
he's always on it isn't he he was for a
long time and then he didn't for a long
time and now he's making his return I
love that you like like you don't care
about the acting as much as you do
friendships yeah I love that about you
he knows exactly what to get out of all
these people I'm gonna be here for two
weeks yeah I got Cubans I'll bring them
down well you want to smoke them
maybe we can smoke em on Yuri Etta
I mean I'm Arrieta Minetta no matter
what Lane what's that on the Velo smoke
them on a street on a stoop yeah now
what are we [ __ ] it's not we
I know but you can't smoke you could
smoke weed more places than you're
allowed to smoke cigars now 900 cigar
shops in Manhattan
you can walk into the Soho's cigar bar
and light up your own Cuban I can I I
gave him a shout-out on Rogen's podcast
and uh so I'm hoping for some love when
I go in how would you work that you walk
into the place they don't know you the
waitress doesn't know you from Adam but
you've been got a shout out at the Soho
cigar bar how do you do it how do i how
do I get free stuff first of all it's
not the MAC store you put a sticker
he put a sticker in there take a
randomly placed in the back Bobby's good
at a mill is enough of a PB snoring they
call it I have a shot Norah first of all
they of Jewish people is offensive to me
secondly I don't like to watch snoring
okay so you walk into the cigar bar they
you've got a shout out on on Twitter
because you mentioned it on a media
outlet as soon as I see the guy the
manager what's up man how are you and I
and I make a face that I've made on
television doesn't work he's told he
told me that he told me this once to get
them at the Apple Store just go in let
them recognize your face from TV and
you'll give her the front of the line I
stood there for an hour nobody
recognized me we were making faces
you've made on TV you should have went
boom hey Jerry well he's already wearing
he's wearing the t-shirts of all the
shows that he's done so that's his way
of he wears his a Letterman Sheridan and
other demographics women 49 to 48 in
Tampa and men 12 to 18 and then 26 to 35
men in Tampa in Tampa all right I'm
gonna have to uh I'll figure it out
but all right when I'll be around you're
going to work here this weekend you're
gonna be here this weekend doing Splott
and I'm going to next Friday I'm going
to Belgium with the family yeah Wow but
I just there was a [ __ ] failed
bombing attempt at the Brussels train
terminal where I'm [ __ ]
going to well they got it out of the way
yeah that wasn't going to do it again
well yeah why wouldn't they because they
usually tried it they did the whole plan
and it did whatever and now they're
moving on to the next thing I just don't
want my I know me I don't care about
because I can Bruce Willis and survived
in any situation but with my wife and my
kid I know I'm gonna be honey
go over there she's gonna bite what go
over there and be quick well I don't
want to go yeah but the thing is but the
thing is when you're I know but when
Yuri what the whole family it's like all
right if we all go out we go out it's
you don't want to be taken out on your
own you want you want everyone to go
because then they're lonely and they
have no money you don't health insurance
what's that
there's some term life insurance Tom
alright good seeing you Bobby we'll see
you next time on your podcast the great
Robert Kelly Bob to see you see him from
across the way
yeah and you think that guy's a scary
dude they said Sammy sounds like it like
a fun little guy he's got like a mini
diet cocaine which is offensive in
itself yeah it's dead steady there
hasn't been diet coke in that can for
several hours just airing it around yeah
got two sips in it alright we do have to
wrap this up we got everywhere we're a
little short or a normal run time but we
have to get over and start rehearsing
for and we actually do we didn't even
talk about Conan which was amazing and
yeah we can put like clips of that in or
just put it on the page and that was
really fun it was fun doing Conan a
green panel you did it out of habit I
got a lot of good feedback I got more
feedback off of that Conan than I think
anyone that I've done yeah it was my
15th anniversary of doing Conan yeah
that was a great story you told you they
have all those clips up I wonder if we
can we can put them on it eventually but
I'm we need we would need a guy that
come through that stuff who we can do
that we could tell people to look it up
online yeah yeah and on the Conan
website but um yeah that was fun it
worked out it worked out pretty well
even though I look pretty fat you think
so yeah what's upsetting is I know that
I was fat and everybody's like no I
don't know what you're talking about
which means that I really
walk around pretty fat so you think that
just because people didn't notice that
you were slender yeah I think you are
way above your fighting weight it kind
of goes against what I'm to talk about
on stage which is you're just you
Paul's Paul right and like someone could
go and be like - Paul gained weight I
would have no idea yeah it's the same
thing when people look at me they're
like that's just Tom and even if I like
working my ass off and being strict and
doing all that stuff and I lose 10
pounds
no one cares so how does that affect the
next several weeks in New York where
you're supposed to be on vacation what
I'm my strategy in New York I brought my
running stuff so I might go for a run
but my running my food strategy is eat
lightly and then go crazy okay last
night I was just I didn't really
yesterday running around doing stuff I
did I had nothing I'd like this tiny
little salad for the whole day yeah and
then went out for an Italian meal and
had pasta prosciutto duck yeah I just
hate everything and no rabbit I ate a
rabbit less oh it's been a whine and I
ate a rabbit
I'll rabbit it was pretty amazing yeah
so that's my strategy and then I haven't
really eaten today so then after the
show I'll go crazy and put my whole face
enough thing and we had a whole tray of
bacon animal the other day we got about
that later but yeah all right we got to
go we have to go get to rehearsal thanks
everybody we'll talk to you soon enjoy
your life
[Music]
you